(bright upbeat music)
- I am Neil Thompson.
I'm the Director of
the Future Tech Project
here at the Computer
Science and AI Lab at MIT.
And we have some questions
about Moore's Law and AI
that I'm gonna be answering today.
"As we approach physical limitations
of silicon-based chip technology,
is Moore's Law still relevant?"
So I think this is a
really important question
because for decades and decades,
computing has been shaped by Moore's Law,
this pattern where as we
miniaturized our transistors,
these fundamental pieces of the chip.
As we miniaturized them,
that allowed us to put more
and more transistors on them.
And that made our computers
much more powerful
and they used those smaller transistors,
used less energy so we
could run chips faster.
And this just meant that
there were all kinds of things
that we could do today
that we just could not do in the past.
As you shrink these things,
at some point you get
down to the atomic level,
and you get to this point where you say,
well, now all of a sudden
we have quantum effects
and other things that are gonna start
interfering with the way
our transistors work.
And that's gonna be a real challenge
to making them ever smaller
and making them ever better.
And in fact, back in 2004 and 2005,
we already lost a big part of that gain
when we stopped our ability
to speed up the processors
that we were using.
Now we're still getting the
last vestiges of Moore's Law.
We can still miniaturize
these transistors more.
And so we're still
getting more transistors,
we just can't run them as fast.
And people may be aware that
we're having these problems now
where sometimes you have to like
turn off parts of your chips
sometimes called dark silicon
in order to not use all
the power at the same time
and produce too much that
would heat up the chip.
So then the question is like,
is Moore's Law still relevant?
And the answer is, it's
relevant for some people
but not for others.
Already, those people
where the speed increase
was the important thing,
they've already lost a lot of the benefit.
And that's actually,
unfortunately many of us, right?
If you're running a lot of
programs on your computer,
a lot of the things you do,
you care mostly about how
fast you can run them.
And we've already lost
a lot of that benefit.
There are however, still some people
who are doing really advanced stuff,
like some of the stuff in AI
and those AI chips are really using
lots and lots of transistors
and so they're still
taking advantage of it.
So that'll still go on for a little while.
Our cell phones are another example,
but we already see this narrowing
of the people who are
benefiting from Moore's Law
and we don't have that much
longer until it's gonna run out.
"What new materials like graphene
or technologies like 3D
stacking in chip design
might contribute to the
trend of Moore's Law
beyond the limitations of silicon?
Unfortunately, the answer
here is that it's pretty hard
to know which of these
technologies are gonna win.
And there are a couple of
reasons why that's true.
So there are some technologies
that are clear are gonna be
useful in the short term.
So 3D stacking is this
idea that previously
mostly our chips were
sort of like a plane,
so it was just like, and it was,
now we might be more like building it up.
So you can imagine sort
of building high rises
rather than having low rise
houses or things like that.
And as we build them up,
we get more and more transistors.
That will definitely
give us some advantages
and we're already using
that in computer memory.
The problem is that when
we run these transistors
in our processors, they produce heat.
And that's been the limitation
for decades and decades.
That production of heat, limits
how fast we can run them.
And the problem is of course,
that if you start stacking these
things on top of each other
and they're all producing heat,
now it's harder to get that heat away.
And so I think 3D stacking
will be useful in some places,
but not that much in others.
Another short term technology
that may matter here as well,
is this idea of what
sometimes called chiplets.
And it's this idea that
rather than designing
each of our chips brand
new, we might build chips
and sort of stick them
together like legos.
And again, that has the possibility
for some small gains in the short run
because it allows us to be
a little bit more modular
and save some costs,
but it doesn't give us the
same kind of scale of benefits
that we had from Moore's Law.
Now in the longer term
we have other things like
spintronics and graphene,
and other things that
people may have heard of,
those things, some of them
have a lot of promise,
but it's really very untested.
These are all early stage technologies.
And one of the things
that I've been talking
to policymakers about
that I think is really important
is that we're just
investing far too little
in generating these next
generation technologies.
So I would say that we probably need
to be investing maybe 10 or
a 100 times as much money
as the United States as we are right now.
So this is a real shortfall
and if we don't invest,
we're gonna have this
longer and longer gap
until these next technologies get here.
And that's gonna mean that the benefits
that we get for computing,
we're just not gonna get
them for much longer.
And so that's a real deficit
that I really think the
government should try and address.
And I hope that we can get the word out
that this is a really
important thing to talk about.
"In the context of slowing
hardware advancements,
what are the key algorithmic
innovations in AI
that continue to drive its success?"
So this is a really interesting
and important question
because if Moore's Law is
slowing, as I've told you,
why is it that we're seeing this
incredible explosion in
AI and how good it is?
And the answer is a couple of things
are going on at the same time.
So one is that AI is better able
to take advantage of computer hardware
than most types of things that we run.
That's just because it can do
more calculations in parallel.
And parallel is something
computers do really well
and AI uses a lot of.
Most of the things we run
don't have that much parallelism
and so it's hard to get
that full advantage of it.
Another is just that AI as
an area actually is making
very rapid progress in algorithms as well.
And so that's a big advantage
that's coming in too.
But the biggest thing
that's driving AI right now
is actually we're just
spending more and more money
to do these models.
And so it used to be,
if you look at a cutting
edge model from the 1970s,
what people are running it on
is just a couple of processors, right?
So think about buying a computer,
and you might have a computer
or you might have a few computers,
but it was running on a relatively
small amount of hardware.
Today when people train GPT-4 for example,
they're running on tens
of thousands of chips
at the same time and they're
not running them for hours,
they're running them for
weeks or even months.
And so there's just a huge amount,
more resources we're putting in.
And that's a big, big part
of why AI is accelerating
even in the face of Moore's Law,
not giving us the efficiency improvements
that we used to have.
"How sustainable is
Moore's Law progression
in light of rising costs
and environmental concerns?
Is there a limit to its economic
or environmental viability?"
It's hard to overstate how
important Moore's Law has been
for the economic and environmental
sustainability of computing.
If you go back and talk
to some of the people
who were at the very
early days of computing,
they're often saying things like,
"We knew that you could
have video conferencing,
we knew that you could do these
really complicated things.
We just knew we didn't have
enough computing power."
And it was just totally
unreasonable to say
we're gonna spend so much money
or devote so many resources
to do these things.
And so they just didn't do them.
And it took decades of
computers getting better
for those things to get into reach
and for us to say, "Okay, now
that's reasonably affordable."
Now that's an amount of resources
we could actually imagine
spending on this problem.
And the challenge we have today
is that as Moore's loss slows down,
we've lost that efficiency gain, right?
Getting twice as many transistors
for the same amount of dollars
or for the same amount of
resources was a huge benefit.
And so for decades and
decades we saw Moore's Law
was sort of driving the
improvement that we had.
But as I just told you,
in AI that's not the case.
The way we're doing in AI
is we are actually scaling that up.
And that means there's a big environmental
and economic cost that is
coming into these models.
And people have estimated
that GPT-4, for example,
cost a hundred million dollars to train
and people are preparing to
spend 10 or a 100 times as much
in some of the coming
models that are going.
So these are enormously expensive systems
that they're building.
And we should start to worry
because those big systems
with all of those resources
also produce more greenhouse gases
and that becomes less and
less sustainable for us.
And so I think one of the
things we need to do is say,
"Well, if we're not
getting that improvement
from Moore's Law and we are
skilling these things up
in this way, what are the other things
that we can do in order
to make these chips
more environmentally and
economically efficient?"
And people are working on that.
There's a lot of really
interesting algorithm work
going on in these areas,
but it's a real challenge
in order to meet,
because right now we're
scaling up even faster
than we're able to do that.
"With the end of Moore's Law,
are we approaching a fundamental shift
in the economic model
of the tech industry?"
I think not only are we moving
to a different economic model,
but we're actually moving
back to an economic model
that looks a lot more like the
things in our regular lives
and away from a model
that was really just very
different and very unusual.
So if I told you, "Oh,
imagine we have a motor."
You would say, "Okay,
I can imagine a motor,
but the motors that I picture
look awfully different."
Right, the motor that's on a
plane is huge and powerful.
The one that is in a blender
is sort of moderately powerful.
And the one that is in like a fan
that is blowing on you is
not very powerful at all.
There's enormous
differences in the materials
and the design choices that are made
for those different types of motors.
Historically for computer chips,
we have not had this
kind of specialization.
Computer chips built these CPUs,
these central processing units,
and they've been designed
to do everything.
In fact, if you talk to Intel
architects, they'll tell you
that you sort of, these
chips are a compromise
so that they do everything well.
And we've had this remarkable durability
of not specializing, of having
just a single technology
that we use for all
kinds of things, right?
And you know, in the rest of
the world that would seem odd.
Imagine a motor that you put in your plane
when you go in an airplane
and then you put on your
blender when you get home,
like that's a very different world.
And so the reason that
we were able to have that
for so long is precisely
because computers were
getting better so fast
that it wasn't worth specializing it.
'Cause you'd say, "Well,
I would get some benefit
of specializing it, but then
I'm gonna get that benefit
from Moore's Law in a year or two anyway.
And so I'd rather just wait
and use this generic technology
that we can all take advantage of."
Okay, so the question asked about this
economic shift, what's happening?
Well, as Moore's Law slows down,
now we need to start specializing
and we're gonna start
specializing in computer chips
in just the way that we do
in almost every other
product in our lives.
And that means we're gonna have chips
that are specifically
designed for our phones.
We already have those.
Chips that are designed for AI.
Okay, we already have those as well,
but we're also gonna get all
kinds of other chips coming in.
And so this is a real departure for it.
And you know, there are horror stories
of people in the '70s and '80s
who thought specialization
is the thing of that moment.
And it wasn't because of Moore's Law.
Now all of those people are
finally getting their moment
and all the specialization is happening.
The great part about that is,
like as we do that specialization,
there are some gains
that we can get from it.
The hard part about it is that
we're gonna get this fragmentation, right?
We're no longer gonna have
a single operating system
that works on these things.
A single programming
language that used in,
you're gonna get all kinds of differences
and things are gonna become
much more specialized.
And that's gonna be a lot more
complicated for the industry
and for all of us as well.
"As we approach the limits of Moore's Law,
how do you see the role
of software optimizations
in advancing computing capabilities?"
So this same benefit that
we were just talking about
of Moore's Law, meaning that
everyone stuck with the same chip,
those gains were also really used
by software designers in the past.
And in particular they were
used to design software
that was very modular.
So imagine this, you might
have like a particular
programming language or
a particular set of code
that is for example, talking
to the hardware, right?
It might be the operating system
or is talking to some external device
or something like that.
You would design that and you would say,
if another program wants to talk to it,
if it wants to say,
"Hey, I wanna use the
microphone on your phone",
or something like that,
it calls that other program and says,
"Do this for me and send
me back the answer."
And there's this very nice clean interface
that says you only have to
tell me these few details
and I'll take care of everything
else behind the scenes.
The problem is that when you do this,
you often pay a cost
in terms of efficiency
that it's often maybe
like in your program,
you're doing analysis at one level
and then you have to convert,
maybe you have to convert the data
or you have to convert the
way that you're handling stuff
into another form so that you can use
this interface that you have.
So that's very inefficient,
but it can be very worthwhile
if it makes programming easier.
As long as Moore's Law
is giving us this benefit
year after year of making
it cheaper and cheaper
to run our chips.
As Moore's Law ends, we lose that gain.
And so now if you wanna make
your programs more efficient,
you're gonna want to take
back that modularization,
that inefficiency that you
were willing to build in
to make programming these things easier.
You're gonna take that back
in order to make running
them more efficient.
And so I think that's a big thing
that people are gonna be doing.
And in some of the work that
we've published in science,
we've shown that in some particular cases
there can be enormous gains
from taking back that efficiency.
"How will the slowing or
potential end of Moore's Law
impact the development of
AI and big data analytics,
which are heavily dependent
on increasing computational power?"
So much of what we're doing
right now to scale up AI
is actually just spending a lot more money
to build more chips and
run more chips for longer
than in the short run,
the change in Moore's Law
is not gonna have much of an effect
because we're scaling up so rapidly.
But as these models get
more and more expensive,
and again, GPT4, it's costing about
a hundred million dollars to train
and people are expecting
the next generations
to be 10 or a 100 times
more expensive, right?
We are indefinitely gonna get to limits
where we say these models
are getting very, very expensive to build.
And then the lack of Moore's
Law is really gonna hurt us
because what you hope and what
we have traditionally had,
is that even if you introduce something
that was very expensive over
time it got much, much cheaper.
So for example, in the
early days of computing,
NASA paid for a lot of computing
power on the spaceship.
But today that amount of
computing is available
for much, much less
because of this progress
that has come from Moore's Law.
What we would hope is that that
would happen in AI as well,
and we will get some of it
because AI is also improving
in terms of its software efficiency
and algorithmic efficiency.
But not having the hardware part
is gonna be a big challenge.